Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, nous allons parler d'un objet culte que beaucoup d'entre vous
ont dans leur salon et que vous utilisez
régulièrement : les consoles de jeux.
Comment sont-elles nées ?
Pourquoi ont-elles rencontré un tel succès ?
À quoi ressembleront celles de demain ?
Sont-elles vouées à disparaître ?
Doit-on s'en inquiéter ?
Vous avez été nombreux à me demander de faire une vidéo sur ce thème.
Comme c'est un sujet très pointu, eh bien j'ai fait appel à un expert, Thomas,
de la chaîne Nightech, spécialisé dans les nouvelles technologies.
Les consoles de jeux,
il adore ça !
Alors c'est lui aujourd'hui qui prend les manettes.
Il est déjà là.
Merci Jamy et merci aux Epicurieuses et aux Epicurieux de m'accueillir.
C'est super sympa.
C'est vrai aujourd'hui, les consoles de salon sont partout.
On a trois acteurs emblématiques
qui dominent Xbox, PlayStation et Nintendo.
Mais un rappel historique s'impose,
histoire de comprendre
comment on en est arrivé au marché actuel.
L'histoire du jeu vidéo commence dans les années 1970 - 1975
avec des boites, comme Atari, qui éditent d'abord des jeux sur bornes d'arcade,
puis qui veulent exporter le concept
à la maison sur des consoles.
À l'époque, le jeu vidéo dans son ensemble,
c'est une industrie neuve et qui génère déjà
des millions de dollars de revenus.
Donc bien sûr, c'est l'eldorado.
Dès qu'un jeu marche, on en sort une dizaine de copies bas de gamme.
On voit apparaître des centaines de consoles
toutes plus anecdotiques les unes que les autres.
Bref, on ne sait pas trop ce qu'on vend,
mais on sait qu'il y a de l'argent à se faire,
donc on y va,
quitte à produire n'importe quoi.
À partir de là, il a suffit que quelques médias commencent
à dire légitimement que le jeu vidéo
c'était un peu naze
pour qu'on assiste à une perte de confiance totale
dans ce marché.
C'est alors que tout le business des jeux et des consoles s'effondre
lors du krach du jeu vidéo de 1983.
Toujours est il qu'à l'issue de cette première bataille,
il n'y a plus ou moins qu'une console
dont le modèle économique reste viable.
La Nintendo Entertainment System ou NES de Nintendo.
L'entreprise japonaise cible en fait avant tout les familles, les enfants.
Ils positionnent le jeu vidéo comme un domaine innocent qui relève du jouet,
et ça leur réussit.
Nintendo sera ensuite
vite suivi par Sega avec sa Master System.
Les deux consoles suivent en fait un petit peu
le même modèle : des jeux de plateformes, de tir, de simulation de course.
Les jeux sont proposés au format cartouche et sont en 2D relativement simple.
Mais pour l'époque, c'était la folie.
Et oui, dès cette génération, du côté de Nintendo,
on retrouve déjà des titres comme Mario
ou The Legend of Zelda.
C'est quand même dingue de voir si tôt
des licences encore mythiques aujourd'hui.
C'est dire le génie créatif de Nintendo à l'époque.
Lors de la génération suivante, le combat entre Sega et Nintendo s'intensifie
avec la Mega Drive, sorti chez nous en 1990, puis la Super Nintendo en 1992.
On est toujours principalement sur de la 2D, avec plus de complexité
et de profondeur dans les graphismes
et le gameplay cette fois.
Et cette génération au niveau jeu,
c'est l'arrivée de Sonic du côté de Sega
pour contrer Mario.
C'est l'ère des jeux de baston également
avec Mortal Kombat et Street Fighter 2.
Mon petit favori pour le coup, ce serait plutôt Shining Force II,
un jeu de rôle en vue du dessus
étonnamment complet pour l'époque.
Si jamais vous êtes curieux, il est
désormais disponible sur smartphone.
Ce duel était bien divertissant, mais c'est là qu'entre en scène Sony,
un géant japonais de l'électronique sans commune mesure avec Sega et Nintendo.
Sony débarque avec la PlayStation chez nous en 1995
et rafle tout lors de la sortie avec des franchises
telles que Gran Turismo, Wipeout ou encore Crash Bandicoot.
Résultat la Saturn de Sega se fait écraser par cette nouveauté.
La Nintendo 64, elle, va résister un petit peu mieux, mais c'est quand même pas brillant.
Cette génération console, qui se développe de 1995 à 2000,
est le théâtre de gros changements technologiques.
C'est l'avènement du support CD.
Il permet de stocker plus de données,
de faire des jeux plus ambitieux, d'inclure de véritables cinématiques, ce genre de choses.
Allié aux meilleures performances des consoles, ça permet au jeu en 3D de se démocratiser.
Le jeu vidéo va donc gagner en complexité, en richesse.
Il va y avoir besoin de davantage de gens et de compétences pour les créer.
Bref, c'est une sacrée période de croissance et de surenchère technique
caractérisée par l'arrivée de classiques
plus contemporains comme Tomb Raider
ou comme le cultissime Super Mario 64
sur lequel j'ai passé des heures
quelques années plus tard sur ma DS.
Et oui, à partir de là, je suis désolé, il y a juste trop de bons jeux.
Je vais citer mes favoris, mais n'hésitez pas
à en faire autant dans les commentaires.
Les consoles vont continuer dans cette dynamique de montée
en puissance et de multimédia et c'est lors de la génération suivante
que le marché va commencer à prendre
la forme qu'on connait aujourd'hui.
À ce moment là, Sega peine un petit peu à suivre le rythme.
Ils vont sortir une dernière console, la Dreamcast, avant de totalement
sortir de ce marché malheureusement.
Sony lui renforce sa nouvelle position de leader avec la PlayStation 2 en 2000.
Nintendo introduit la GameCube en 2002 et enfin Microsoft,
qui avait un petit peu peur
que les consoles ne commencent à faire
de l'ombre au PC, débarque
avec sa propre console, la première Xbox.
Alors là, de la 3D toujours, plus de pixels, plus de puissance,
plus de moyens.
Et si vous avez mon âge, plus de souvenirs aussi.
J'ai passé des jours entiers à jouer à Jak and Daxter, Ratchet et Clank,
le premier fable également.
Et j'ai découvert l'excellent Super Smash
Bros mêlée il n'y a pas longtemps.
Une très belle époque, quoi.
Autre grosse nouveauté qui va tout
changer,
c'est avec cette génération de console
que le jeu en ligne commence
à se développer.
Chose qui sera exploitée à fond lors de la génération suivante
avec la Xbox 360 en 2005, puis la PlayStation 3 fin 2006.
On joue alors en haute définition, en ligne, avec des manettes sans fil.
Les bases des consoles actuelles sont posées là.
La suite, vous la connaissez !
Les mêmes acteurs dominent dans la continuité.
Nintendo, de son côté, décide de toujours prioriser sa cible familiale
et son axe de l'expérience de jeu, avant tout avec la Wii, puis la Wii U
et l'actuelle Switch.
Ce qui est malin, ça leur évite d'affronter frontalement
Sony et Microsoft.
De leur côté, on a des consoles qui ressemblent beaucoup à des PC
techniquement. Ultra performantes et relativement abordables,
avec les séries PS4, Xbox One, puis PS 5 et Xbox séries S et X.
Et si ces consoles sont plutôt abordables, ce n'est pas pour rien.
C'est parce que leur fabricant adopte un business model bien précis
qui est celui de l'économie de plateforme.
L'idée, c'est en tant qu'entreprise de se poser
en intermédiaire entre l'offre et la demande sur un marché donné.
De cette façon,
on génère des revenus plus ou moins
automatiquement en assurant la liaison
entre ceux qui proposent un service et ceux qui souhaitent y accéder.
C'est ce que font Uber, Airbnb Apple avec l'App Store,
les réseaux sociaux quelque part.
Bref, à l'ère des plateformes numériques, c'est extrêmement rentable.
C'est ce que font Sony, Microsoft et Nintendo depuis longtemps en fait.
Ils posent leur console comme intermédiaire entre nous, qui
souhaitons acheter et jouer à des jeux
et les éditeurs qui créent et proposent les jeux à la vente.
La valeur qu'ils apportent, c'est que pour que nous, les joueurs, puissions jouer
il nous faut un ordinateur, une console pour faire tourner des jeux.
Et pour que les éditeurs puissent vendre des jeux.
Il faut aussi qu'il y ait un public, le plus large possible,
pour l'acheter et maximiser ses profits.
Les consoles sont donc vendues
à bas coûts pour s'assurer un large parc de joueurs
et donc être sûr d'attirer l'attention et les faveurs des éditeurs de jeux vidéo.
Là où les fabricants de consoles se font de l'argent, c'est en fait après,
sur leurs commissions qui s'élèvent à 30% sur chaque vente
de jeux ou toute transaction qui s'effectue sur leur store.
Pour l'instant, les fabricants de console
profitent donc de leur position
d'intermédiaire obligé obtenu en subventionnant l'accès au matériel
qui permet de faire tourner
les jeux vidéo.
Sauf qu'en ce moment, un phénomène est lentement
mais sûrement en train de bouleverser
les habitudes de jeux :
le cloud gaming.
Le cloud gaming, ça désigne le fait non pas de lancer un jeu vidéo
sur sa console ou son PC, mais de le lancer en streaming.
Celui-ci tourne alors sur un serveur distant,
puis arrive chez vous via votre connexion Internet,
à condition d'en avoir une excellente bien sûr.
C'est un usage qui est de plus en plus pertinent à mesure
que la 5G et la fibre se démocratisent.
Et donc, à terme, l'idée, c'est de pouvoir
jouer sur n'importe quel appareil,
partout et tout le temps, sans console
ou boîtier intermédiaire quelconque.
Sur le marché du jeu vidéo, c'est une sacrée barrière à l'entrée qui tombe
et qui permet à d'autres acteurs de venir essayer de récupérer des joueurs
sans devoir entrer en concurrence avec
les colosses que sont Sony et Microsoft
sur le marché, somme toute assez complexe, du matériel et des consoles de jeu.
Citons Stadia de Google ou encore GeForce Now
du fabricant de matériel informatique
Nvidia.
Et bien entendu, Sony et Microsoft ont fini par entrer dans la mêlée
avec le GamePass et avec le PS Now.
Le problème pour Sony et Microsoft, au delà de cette concurrence naissante,
c'est que, dans un monde sans console, uniquement dans le cloud,
tu fais comment pour fidéliser un joueur
et te faire de l'argent
sur la vente de jeux,
puisque plus rien n'empêche le joueur
d'utiliser simultanément
plusieurs plateformes de jeux vidéo
en streaming.
Il n'a plus besoin de dépenser 500 €
pour utiliser la plateforme concurrente dès maintenant.
La seule chose qui reste pour fidéliser
les joueurs dans ce système,
ce sont les contenus.
C'est ça qui explique que Microsoft ait pu dépenser
70 milliardsde dollars pour acheter
Activision il y a quelques semaines.
Les créateurs de Call of Duty, Tony Hawk, tout ça.
Et c'est aussi pour ça que Sony a dépensé quelque 4 milliardsde dollars
pour acheter Bungie, les éditeurs de Halo ou encore de Destiny.
Bref, l'avenir s'annonce cool.
Je ne sais pas si j'ai envie de voir les consoles disparaitre.
Personnellement, j'avoue que je reste
super attaché à ces petits objets.
Mais bon, la perspective d'être encore plus libre
dans notre pratique du jeu vidéo est alléchante.
Il faut avouer.
Merci Thomas. C'était top !
En tout cas, ça m'a vraiment donné envie de me refaire
une petite partie de Mario Kart.
Bon, si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
et à vous abonner à la chaîne.
Et surtout à inscrire la liste de vos envies en commentaire.
Pour nos prochaines vidéos,
nous lisons tout.
A très bientôt chers Epicurieuses et Epicurieux.